[Music]
hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots it is
me yes that's
right and
I wait till you see this one I'm so
excited for you guys to see this
one I love my I think I know what this
is going to be what do you think you
know hate my is it a female so let's get
after it and have us a good
time some good [__] bread [__]
bread God this you know what the Chris
Cuomo intro I'm not going to lie always
makes me hungry yeah me too it looks so
good it was good bread okay here we
go he is in he is he's interviewing
somebody with Tourette syndrome yep much
for coming
and what do you hope you can do by
taking the risks that you take so people
can understand what you're dealing
with I'm sorry do you mind repeating the
question [__] off why do you what do
you um I want people to learn that um
Tourette is neural is a neurological
involuntary motor and first off if you
ever [__] talk to me like that again
I'll [__] slap your father how's that
[__] sound I wish I wish her Tourette
was her saying Fredo oh my God yes local
disorder [__] off [__] off [__] off um I
don't tick 247 and I look I want you to
look at his face and see how hard he's
trying not to laugh at this poor woman
right of course there's a lot
of little baby is [__]
off
okay [__] I like that she has British
tourettes [__] you Chris she just said
[__] you Chris a lot of things that
people don't understand like look at his
face I mean how do you not I would be
laughing people think that cussing isn't
is with everyone who has Tourette
Syndrome but it's only in 10% of people
with
Tourette's oh so she's one of the lucky
ones yeah she's the one that could get
away with
murder and how has it been as you've
gotten more famous do you believe that
people are understanding
better or are they dopes like me who
think you're acting are they dopes like
me who think you're acting oh he thinks
she's full of [__] that's what he said
yeah I say it's I say yeah he said here
listen gotten more famous do you believe
that people are understanding better or
are they dopes like me who think you're
acting yeah that was very passive
aggressive
little oh um no I mean I'm not saying
wow Chris way to way to attack a neurod
Divergent woman I'm not saying that
people don't lie about that but I
definitely know people that really do
have Tourette's that they really do Cur
that's I mean it's she is correct by
saying it's not everyone with Tourette's
it's a small percentage but it's a real
thing MH it it really really is I mean
because people had this before there was
YouTube you know what I mean where it
wasn't for make a f I'm not saying it's
normal it's a small percentage but it is
a real mental
thing I say it's I say it's the
same I think there's a lot more people
that don't understand what Tourette is
and um they like to educate their
themselves more so I get thousands of
DMS from parents from teachers
from girls that have been diagnosed with
Tourette's and they've had to be kicked
out of school for attention seeking
because they rip up they rip up their
homework or do things like that I've had
Parents reach out to me asking me oh my
son's coming home with a girlfriend and
his girlfriend has Tourette
Syndrome so and then I also get very
evil people that would comment and say
like go [__] yourself Chris L your baby
we ah he really thinks that she's acting
though look at his face because he's a
[__] grease ball and [__] grease
balls cannot have anybody they they take
that very offensive we've seen him when
with hitting cameras what a [__]
tough guy he is and no one disrespects
aomo that kind of guy and this the fact
that this girl I don't think she's
Faking It honestly because she doesn't
she's not just doing the cursing she
does have if you know people with
Tourette's like there's some people that
she has the ticks that like unless she's
really good you know and say like go
[__] yourself Chris B and blow up your
ass blow it up your ass the black hold
on no no blow it out your ass she said
go [__] yourself Chris little baby
weener blow it out your ass but she said
blow it out your ass like a black girl
like a s she do different dialect and
they're mean and they're stupid and they
try to make themselves feel better by
going after others and you are the
antidote my young friend because you
have my
kids hey I'm
talking little baby
B Chris hey quit interrupting me when
I'm doing my
monologues whatever di is flipping off
the camera there you go how's that I
love her you know what I love her I love
her more if she is faking
it my kids repeating your lines so that
it's almost become cool and not because
you know it's runchy it's because you're
being real and you're living your truth
but you said earlier you thought you was
faking Chris I I think that was a
Freudian slip and they love it they love
The Bravery of it and so do I and I love
how you've changed your mission you were
at
University what are you what I say you I
say at University now like you were at
you were at hospital right did they
check you out there sorry I went on the
Harry Potter tour with my wife so I'm
still doing the accents I started saying
H for the letter now
too covid was tough for you tougher than
for most right really blew up your
symptoms and now you want to be a
physical therapist because exercise
helps you what happens let's say when
you're doing physical therapy and then
you get all [__] again you have one
of your little [__] ticks what happens
like do I get
hurt and do you think God will forgive
you what you think God will forgive you
for talking to your parents that way
just thought you
me you think God will forgive you
because he's clearly parished you yeah
so I got a question now for you uh so my
mother's been watching how do you feel
about making a
cry questions for out of touch
question during interview do you think
God God will forgive you yeah do you
think God will forgive you for what I'll
give you time to answer I'm just been
what a smug question that would be to
ask anybody
during ask Owen it when he comes on you
think God
for yeah you think God will forgive you
for uh talking to me this
way what do you think for interrupting
me when I was talking I was doing a
monologue over
here you obviously used to your famous
you don't have a lot of broadcast
experience like I do don't talk over
me I love this [__] idiot me
Paul yes so I go to the gym 5 days a
week and I go to a workout oh my God I
would work out with her she would be my
workout buddy oh my God are you [__]
kidding me that's all I want to do is
work out with this [__] is here just
are you kidding me look at her she's if
you went to her gym she be like get away
from me creep and stop raping me and
then she'll be like is that the I'll be
like is that the Tourette or
[Laughter]
or do you really hate me I every white
woman at a gym is toess yeah seriously
they go around screaming stop raping me
and you're like don't walk in front of
my camera you just dropped your Fitbit I
was trying to give it back stupid [__]
Christ um splitting it throughout the
week um I love exercise my boyfriend got
me into it ah sorry
fellas um I've been doing it for about a
year now now your boyfriend does he also
yell out all kinds of curse words yeah
yeah cuz I can't slap a woman but I'll
slap your
boyfriend is your boyfriend is he bigger
than me
mhm it's my last question what does it
feel like that God's forsaken
you what's that
like you ever get mad at him or whatever
yeah I don't know it's my release um I
obviously go to the gym and I wear
headphones and that's also a very big
factor in how [__] off [__] Colin [__]
that [__] [__] [__] Colin [__] that
[__] whoa um smash though right Jesus
Christ didn't real she that that's also
a really big like part in my journey was
starting out with
him well I love seeing him in the videos
you guys have a great Bond I love
everything about your family and I love
the story you're telling to people live
in your
truth and my kids my you know what I am
you're done [__] you I I she's the best
I love her I'm done I got to go to phone
calls cuz they're blowing up with
support for you I'm sure so I hope you
can watch it blow up that she's a pretty
girl she just said blow up that wiener
sorry we got to hear that for you so I
hope you can watch it blow up that
wiener at home and listen to everybody
who wants to say great things to you
Balin Dupri thank you for what you're
doing thank you no no no hey Chris thank
you for this interview yeah thank you
buddy what you did was thank you for
what you're doing which is floundering
and it's been really fun to watch that
will be a clip uh that will be a god
Chris has been [__] floundering and
is that is there anything better than
watching him try to like maintain any
relevance yo my kiss say you're big on
Tik Tok you want to come on my
show dude Chris
Kobo unintentionally is making the best
content right
now think about it he guys like Tourette
scr on and then he'll have like [__]
bill o in the next second
yep